joining us now here on the Rich Eisen
show my buddy from the NFL Media Group
Ian Rapoport how are you brother
I'm good rich sorry about the delay we
were taping a segment of one more thing
on NFL now and just to let you know yes
sir as serious it was one of our rules
as the work-from-home situation has
progressed
if someone interrupts your live shot you
have to put that person on TV eat so my
dog Molly is gonna be on one more thing
on TV because she was barking very very
loudly these things happen sir these
things happen you know kids I saw a DD
King Cabrales beautiful family made a
cameo the other day on camera these
things happen yeah and we are one that
we are one family at the NFL Media Group
so let's let's start things off with
some real football conversations I keep
saying that Jamal Adams conversation
wanting about having trade etc and
everybody else picking up on where can
he go who could be interested but to me
that's just a non-starter why in the
world with the Jets with two years of
contractual control trade this guy you
tell me if I'm wrong I'm with you I'm
with you and I get it because this you
know this happens frequently anytime
there's you know trade rumors it's
always like alright you know and look
we're in the entertainment world I get
it so on TV though it's like art you
know who's the best fit for Jamal and
you know who's a very good fit good jets
very good fish yes he is he's young he's
great he is sort of a you know kind of a
leader type very emotional so maybe not
the classic leader but but you know can
kind of get the team charged up two
years of control on his contract and
then the other thing is Joe Douglas is
in his first time as a general manager
he's still trying to establish the
parameters of his team he's not going to
give in to the whims of a player or do a
get sort of forced into doing a contract
with two years to go I mean this is all
about setting precedent and my gut says
that the Jets just go okay we'll see
what happens and if Jamal Adams wants to
hold out given that the CBA basically
becomes holdout proof good luck to him
plus again on top of it just it makes no
sense for them to make a move right now
I mean what are they afraid he's not
gonna show up to the Microsoft team
meeting I mean you know what I'm saying
it's not like there's even on field work
that we can see is happening right now
it's in the draft in which they would
actually accrue the the picks even if
somebody bowls them over with first
rounders that doesn't help for 2020 when
you're trying to evaluate Sam Donald or
at least get him in the right direction
after a remarkably you know surprising
finish by the team last year none of it
makes sense
none of it from the jets point of view
and and then the other thing is look
let's just say for argument's sake that
a trade is possible and I you know I
know there's some interest I haven't
heard anyone like banging down the Jets
door but you know there's there's
certainly some interest okay so you
trade for Jamaa times you give up a
first rounder for a safety seems
far-fetched but I guess crazier things
have happened
and then you know you gotta pay them
then you give up a first you pay sixteen
million dollars for a safety you know
not all teams would even pay that to one
of their own safety it's not a position
that traditionally has been one of the
highest-paid or the the focuses of you
know getting those guys under contract
now he's a good player I get that but
that's insanely expensive to do all of
that so it's possible but I wouldn't
describe it as likely he and Rappaport
here on the Rich Eisen show I love the
words that you and the rest of our
colleagues in this business use it's
it's you know you're gonna leave
yourself some wiggle room because you
never know if something's crazy can
happen on that front but you know again
I would say I would say this rich in the
trade world and now that the NFL is to
come on trade crazy the last three years
just I have forced myself to never say
that's crazy it's not happening because
I've been told I was like 45 minutes
before Calais Campbell was traded to the
Ravens yes I was told it's not happening
and I didn't report it and then it
literally happened so as you mentioned
I'm sure you could fill the rest of our
segment with stories like that over your
entire career you know and then you see
colleagues of yours at different outlets
break it anyway and then you call
somebody up and say what the hell was
that all about
I'm sure we could fill the rest of this
session on that I could fill a
dictionary with the words I've used
instead of hell but yes uh-huh
very good Ian Rapoport here on the Rich
Eisen show read me the tea leaves of
wide ACK signed his tender this week out
of out of is it out of the blue I mean
what what is the strategy here with July
15th being a long-term contractual
deadline for he and the Cowboys so as
far as I could tell this was actually
the plan all along and you know I think
for for every franchise player you want
the long-term contract right and you
want to be able to kind of do whatever
you want because you're not actually
under contract with the tag so what a
lot of guys do is you know you sign it
the third week of the preseason you roll
in you get a little work and then you
just play the season that's a pretty
standard move for you know players who
are franchised you lock in your money
you miss training camp and whatever
that's that but this year given the
pandemic there's some uncertainty so
guys a lot more guys this year wanted to
lock in their salaries just in case and
back wanted the same but you know I
think there's been a little bit of an
effort to make sure that the Cowboys
know he's not going to do a team
friendly deal and he's not gonna be
khana the-- I hate to say this but like
the goody-two-shoes that most
quarterbacks are he's he's going to take
a strong business stance and in this
case that meant staying away for the
virtual offseason so his plan was to
sign it right when the virtual offseason
ended and it ended for the Cowboys last
week huh so he signed it on Monday ok so
then so then he's he's now in the fold
I imagine the issue is how the salary
caps affected bykova 19 in future years
and how cap strung that could leave the
Cowboys is that what the issue is now
on top of all the you know back and
forth that may have been going on
between DAC and the Cowboys to keep this
thing is an open question to this point
that definitely is a concern and what
the thought process now is that the NFL
in the NFLPA will somehow be able to get
the cap to be flat next year there's
going to be some some lost revenue you
know could be as much as 40 or 50
million dollars per team but then you
have the new TV deals you know there are
ways where they can sort of make up the
money and finagle it so the cap is flat
so it's an issue but the parties
involved think they will be able to work
it out what's more of an issue in Dax
case is there's been a trend for players
now to do shorter term deals you know
it's not as sexy to say you know like
the numbers don't look as big when you
do a three-year deal but for a player
it's much better because you can
reappear so that's what dak wants a
four-year deal the Cowboys have only
offered five years and I honestly don't
know which side caves it might be
neither side and if a deal doesn't get
done that's why Ian Rapoport joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show and then the
issue of a season I put it in front of
you you must get asked this all the time
I get asked this all the time what do
you think about a 2020 season and I my
response is the same that the virus will
have the last say but everything that I
know and hear is at the NFL has every
intention of playing what are you here
yeah yeah the same and obviously this
rich it's incredible the amount of
really good smart successful coaches
agents you know high up executives who
will call and ask are we gonna have a
season it's a you know usually I would
say like you ask your owner or some but
nobody actually knows so that's it's
been it's been weird to hear like you
know very good football coaches call and
be like so what do you think you know
that's just been it's just been an odd
dynamic cuz they don't call me and ask
about play calling you know but they do
ask this is going to be a season and
I get the same sense you do that it is
going to go on as scheduled with minimal
fans to start and then we'll see I think
the most important thing really of of
all the things that have we've heard the
most important thing was dr. Allen sells
the and of those chief medical officer
saying there are going to be positive
tests it is going to happen get used to
it it will happen it will be a storyline
it will happen and once you accept that
there will be some positive test you can
see how it would go on
you know let's say let's say just a lot
you know let's say you have two a week
per team let's just say that seems like
a lot but let's just say that's the case
so that's you know more than 60 per week
per week
okay well that's basically like two
players being injured for a week or two
however long the quarantine is they get
better they test negative and then they
move on I mean that's I think what the
season is going to be like and the
protocols are so strict that the players
basically if the players don't go out
and don't put themselves in danger it
seems like it's going to be okay yeah I
guess so I mean the issue is though is
that you know with an injury normally
like a sprained MCL suffered by a player
doesn't threaten the life of the aging
assistant coach that's still in the same
mix that's the obvious you know
difference between what what what we're
supposing together here and what may
actually happen with somebody testing
positive for kovat and I'm just
wondering what the players are thinking
based on what your you're hearing
Malcolm Jenkins who was hired by CNN to
be a correspondent or at least an
analyst I guess is a better phrase here
when I was told CNN this morning called
football a non-essential business so we
don't need to do it the risk has to be
really eliminated before we before I
would feel comfortable with going back
you know I've mentioned I think to you
before and I say to pretty much
everybody who's an NFL person coming on
here like thank goodness the Players
Association and the NFL agreed to a
ten-year
the bargaining agreement right before
the Pamuk because it would be a totally
different ball right so you're in here
your reaction means that you would agree
with me but what are you hearing from
players right now that you talk to on
this front I mean just just quickly you
bring this up like I actually think
about what would have happened had they
not agreed right and you know a week
later the pandemic and the world shuts
down like would they have reloaded I
mean I don't know you're right I mean
thank ya thank everything that this
actually happened because ten years of
financial security is much much better
than not well you see what baseball is
going through it they're CBA coming up
at the end of the 2021 season I mean all
the negotiations to just get back on the
field this year was fraught with with
all the you know lack of trust that any
collective bargaining agreement
conversation would have even though
their CBA doesn't you know elapse until
after next season but what so now I'll
let you answer the question are you
hearing that players might be echoing
what what Malcolm told CNN today that
maybe when it comes down to it they
might not want to report
I have heard probably not as much of
that as I thought I might you know like
I i I just don't think this is all sort
of anecdotal because obviously I can't
talk to all the players but I really get
the sense that most of the guys are like
okay it's not that bad we're gonna
figure this out which you know we don't
know we I mean that's one of the
problems we don't know how bad it is
like there are some people saying like
oh you know players should get it now
and then they won't have to worry about
it during the season we don't even know
first of all to everyone 100% recover we
don't know if you can get it again it's
absolutely incredible the amount of
things that we as a world just don't
know but I feel like most players are
okay with taking the risk not to leaving
that is a big risk and also you know
again like the protocols are hard core I
mean it is intense and
I think that is really going to end up
helping in the long run see I guess well
I I guess to wait and see aspect of it I
honestly I feel like sometimes I I need
a degree in public health to do the job
that I'm doing right now in the same way
I needed a you know a legal labor degree
back during the the lockout so what are
you here is it on a report date I mean
cuz it's rubbers gonna have to meet the
road very very soon I mean the amount of
time that that the NFL has had to wait
and see how the circumstances the virus
on the ground could affect their season
what are you hearing about a full-on
report date late July July 28th is a
date that's been thrown out out there
what are you hearing on that front end
yeah sounds like July 28th there's a
date and that was actually the original
date and I've made way too many phone
calls to try to figure out when players
are gonna report only to be told
yesterday that there's been no change
so basically teams are gonna report the
28th and they'll kind of just start
going and you know I'll be curious to
see if the NFLPA mandates a ramp-up
period like okay for the first week you
can't do football or for the first week
it's only strengthen condition I don't
know but this is why I think it's going
to go slow and then this is why there's
probably going to be only two or maybe
less preseason games because it's going
to take a while to build back up to
football where everyone's kind of safe
and alloted it's just kind of go back to
one things you mentioned before which
you know I don't I don't like let's say
that something happens where it goes bad
well just there's an outbreak and just a
lot of players or testing positive I
don't know when there is a point they
would say okay we're shutting it down
like that's what I of all the questions
I've asked that's been one that there's
been no answer
you know they're gonna do everything
right they're going to administer the
protocols they're going to test there's
going to be positive those guys will be
isolated they'll be quarantined I just
don't know what happens if there is a
worst-case scenario and let's just all
hope for those of us who love football
that it never happens are you hearing
about
you know different types of newfangled
testing or new you know like the NBA
again isn't gonna have the players
wearing a magic ring around there around
there you know wrists that's normally
used to open doors and things like that
and gain access it in Disneyworld are
going to outfit it for some sort of
coronavirus test you know tracking or
awareness system are you hearing
anything about that in no no I feel like
those are not to minimize the scientific
progress that those associated with that
development have made but then we got
seem like those brass bands that they
have infomercials for we were like okay
this brass band is gonna make sure I'm
healthy like I don't know I don't know
yeah you like that one Chris those like
the sleeves the copper sleeves like who
knows yeah I don't know right right I
just don't know I just think the NFL has
so many ins and so much you know money
to be able to throw at this that we're
gonna find something out I don't know
maybe that's just uh you know hoping for
for too much but it does seem again I
haven't heard a single soul saying this
isn't you know we need to be we're gonna
we're gonna push it we're gonna delay it
I haven't heard that at all zero except
a fact today people I've heard right
only people I've heard that I've talked
about that have been really just head
coaches who are nervous but in people
really in power no one has said that
words like you mentioned a lockout like
at the time it was always like get ready
to miss games get ready to miss games
prepare for anything and then they
didn't miss any games and I was like
okay but this has been the opposite
every person in power that I asked on
all sides yep they're gonna play i
hearing the same thing in i'm hearing
the same exact thing alright um
appreciate the time I hope you are and
in the meantime we could just all huddle
around the warmth of Jay Cutler's new
Instagram account right I mean of all
the guys of all the guys watch the whole
I I watched every second of his IG
stories and I am
all in on Houthi chicken serial killer
is violent
have you heard any information on that
Ian I know you're tracking down many
stories in the NFL but have you have you
found out any information about that at
all
you know what I have a pretty good
source close to Jay color yes I'm gonna
text right now to see if I can break the
story of who's killing the chicken
already posted on IG all right I mean
I've got Urlacher's number two so I'm
aware of that Ian thanks the call
appreciate it yeah take care you guys
that's a and rap before the NFL media
group hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here